Panic and terror gripped everyone in the Foundation
facility…
well, everyone who was still alive, that is.
Guards were working tirelessly to fight back
and regain control of the building, but they
didn’t have enough bullets to suppress the
oncoming horde.
Somehow, a sample of SCP-008 that was being
examined for testing purposes had managed
to spread to one of the research staff.
Before long, the very same researcher was
now a mindless zombie, a reanimated corpse
that had managed to bite several other staff
members, spreading the infection.
It didn’t matter that this original carrier
was shot down by security personnel, it had
already done its damage and passed on SCP-008.
By now, there were too many of them to simply
bonk each one on the head and neutralize it.
The Foundation facility had gone into a full-scale
lockdown, an emergency quarantine to try and
limit the spread of the deadly virus.
Any exit to the outside world was shut, and
would stay sealed tight unless someone from
the Foundation could do something.
But that meant the few surviving members of
staff trapped inside were at the mercy of
the zombie horde.
Their options were limited; SCP-500 was known
to perfectly cure those infected with SCP-008,
but with all exits locked, it was impossible
to get any of the remaining SCP-500 pills
on site.
Then, one of the surviving researchers, one
Doctor Omel, had an idea; it was an insanely
risky plan, one that the Foundation would
never sign off on.
But desperate times called for desperate measures.
Gathering up the remaining security forces
that hadn’t been infected with SCP-008,
along with a research assistant that had managed
to escape the zombies, Doctor Omel and his
band of survivors headed deeper into the facility.
While the external doors were all locked to
prevent the SCP-008 infectees from making
it out and spreading the virus to the wider
world, the doors inside the facility were
all still functioning.
And it was a good thing, too.
Doctor Omel’s plan relied on opening the
doors to two anomalies: SCP-914, the Clockworks,
a machine capable of destroying or refining
anything placed inside it… and SCP-049,
the Plague Doctor.
It was a shot in the dark at best.
Omel had observed the Plague Doctor for some
time, and knew that the beak-faced surgeon
was capable of creating zombie-like creatures
known as SCP-049-2, not dissimilar from the
zombies infected with SCP-008.
If anyone could potentially fix this nightmare,
there were few as well versed in anomalous
medicine as SCP-049.
Taking him to the Clockworks was, however,
an even bigger risk.
Normally, SCP-049 killed any he touched, and
turned their deceased bodies into SCP-049-2s,
hence Doctor Omel calling for a refinement
of the Plague Doctor’s abilities.
Placing him in the Input booth of SCP-914
and setting it to ‘Very Fine’, Omel prayed
he’d made the right call; he could hear
the horde of SCP-008 pounding outside the
locked door…
What emerged from the Clockworks was still
recognizable as SCP-049, retaining his beaked
mask – although the mask itself was actually
flesh and bone, a part of his skull.
His robes now flowed out behind him as a pair
of dark, feathery wings, giving him an even
more bird-like appearance.
Despite this, SCP-049 had claimed that he’d
never been a bird before.
“Didn’t expect wings, I’ll admit,”
the surviving assistant remarked.
“It’s not so surprising, really,” Doctor
Omel admitted.
“He did lay an egg that one time.”
“What, he did what?!”
Before an explanation could be given, the
SCP-008 zombies managed to break down the
door and came flooding into the room.
Omel recoiled in horror as they snarled and
shuffled closer, reaching towards him with
decrepit fingers.
Suddenly, SCP-049 swooped into the path of
the encroaching undead with a flap of his
new wings.
Calmly, he gave a gentle move of his hand,
like lifting something from a shelf.
A bizarre contraption appeared around his
forearm, a gauntlet connected to syringes
that were strapped to each of his fingers,
all filled with various different fluids.
Doctor Omel was amazed, SCP-049 seemed to
now have the anomalous ability to summon surgical
equipment from a tiny pocket dimension.
It was almost exactly like SCP-076-2, Able,
drew his weapons.
Reaching towards the nearest SCP-008 zombie,
still moving with the utmost calm, SCP-049
stated:
“Now, try to hold still,” he spoke in
a gentle voice, with a bedside manner most
medical doctors would be incapable of.
“This might sting a little.”
With that, SCP-049 pushed the syringes into
the zombie, the fluids draining from each
one, then refilling as he withdrew his hand.
The SCP-008 instance froze for a moment, almost
like it was confused, before it began to emit
what looked to be steam, as though it had
stepped out of a hot shower.
Shaking uncontrollably, the necrosis and tell-tale
signs of infection seemed to disappear, like
being washed away, until all that was left
of the SCP-008 zombie was the infected researcher
it had been before.
The man was alive and well, much to Doctor
Omel’s astonishment.
SCP-049 hadn’t just cured the SCP-008 infection,
he’d actually reversed it, leaving the infectee
alive and well.
It took a few hours for SCP-049 to fly around
the facility on his new wings, effortlessly
turning all the SCP-008 zombies back into
their old selves one by one.
By the time he was done, everyone on site
that had previously been exposed to SCP-008
was cured.
And it didn’t stop there.
The Foundation still mandated everyone who
was previously infected to remain in quarantine
whilst they were examined, remanding the now
refined SCP-049 back to his cell, which he
politely complied with.
When the SCP Foundation doctors took a look
at the formerly zombified staff, they were
amazed at what they found.
Each one had all traces of SCP-008 completely
removed from their systems.
Trying to re-expose them to the virus, their
bodies now seemed able to generate anomalous
antibodies that rejected and fought off infection
by SCP-008 in a manner of seconds.
The Plague Dcotor had made everyone immune.
Upon further testing, examining skin and blood
cells from the former infectees, and performing
full top-to-bottom health checks, the Foundation
doctors learned something else too.
Everyone that SCP-049 had cured was even healthier
than they had been before.
One security guard had been a one-pack-a-day
smoker for ten years, but an X-Ray revealed
any damage to his lungs, mouth, and throat
had all been completely reversed.
On every possible internal and external level,
the formerly zombified personnel had all been
returned to pristine health by SCP-049.
Eager to witness the full extent of these
new anomalous abilities the Clockworks had
given him, the SCP Foundation struck a deal
with SCP-049.
If he performed a mission for them, then they
would provide him with the means to have anything
he wanted.
For a moment, the Plague Doctor pondered their
terms, and then agreed.
“What is it you want in return?”
Doctor Omel had asked.
“To cure the world, Doctor,” SCP-049 replied
simply.
The Plague Doctor flew as fast as his wings
would carry him to the location the Foundation
had given him.
It was an isolated region in Siberia, kept
completely cut off from the rest of the world
by guards working around the clock.
Arriving at the edge of the frozen town, SCP-049
was approached by the security commander,
and given his full directive from the Foundation.
“Your objective, I’m told, is simple:
you enter the restricted area, and neutralize
anything you come into contact with.
When you’re done, return here and we’ll
report the results to command.”
“Thank you, Commander,” the Plague Doctor
nodded graciously.
“You’ve been most helpful.”
He didn’t ask what was out there, merely
turned and began walking through the snow
until he could no longer be seen by the eye.
Maybe he had already sensed what was out there,
what kind of sickness plagued this place,
and understood exactly the Foundation were
asking him to do about it.
If SCP-049 had any questions, he didn’t
make them known.
Instead, he just headed off in search of every
instance of SCP-610 he could find.
There was quiet for an uncomfortably long
while.
The personnel standing guard at the edge of
the area watched through the snowfall, ready
if anything started slithering its way towards
them.
The Foundation security all tensed when the
motion sensor picked up movement, accompanied
by the sounds of fighting, and the bizarre,
inhuman noises instances of SCP-610 made.
Then, after another long period of unsettling
quiet, somebody spotted a gently glowing light
making its way through the snow.
As it drew closer, the glow of the burning
makeshift torch made it clear the figure holding
it was SCP-049.
And as he made his way towards the rendezvous
point, it quickly became apparent he wasn’t
alone.
Shivering in the freezing cold and wet from
the snow, covered in scraps of dirty clothing
and whatever else they could find, was a huddled
mass of people.
All of them looked bewildered, following the
light of SCP-049’s torch like a guiding
beacon towards the edge of the perimeter.
The Foundation security all stood slack-jawed
in amazement at what happened, while the Plague
Doctor led the people and urged the commander
that they all needed warmer clothing immediately.
He’d done it: SCP-049 had cured the Flesh
That Hates.
In the coming months, the Foundation soon
found themselves very busy.
Everyone who had previously been infected
by SCP-610 needed to be screened and examined,
just to make absolutely sure there was no
chance they could mutate into a fleshy monstrosity
again.
But, just like before with the former SCP-008
zombies, these people were all in perfect
condition: cured and healthier than they had
ever been.
By using his new anomalous surgical skill
and healing power, SCP-049 had returned the
Flesh That Hates’ victims back into human
beings.
It was starting to seem like there was no
disease, no infection – anomalous or otherwise
– that he couldn’t cure.
The Foundation began an effort to rehouse
the former SCP-610 infectees.
Given that most of them had spent years as
aggressive anomalous abominations, almost
every one of them had been officially pronounced
dead and couldn’t just go back to their
old lives.
The SCP Foundation gradually reintroduced
them into the world, setting up new identities
and integrating them into new countries.
SCP-049 even personally helped console some
of those that struggled with the adjustment,
offering to give them therapy to aid in the
process.
He was more than just a Plague Doctor, it
seemed, thanks to the Clockworks.
SCP-049’s good work didn’t stop with curing
the Flesh That Hates, either.
As promised, the Foundation allowed him to
carry out his newfound purpose.
Whereas before, he was obsessed with eradicating
what he called ‘The Pestilence’, now the
Plague Doctor seemed to be directing all of
his focus to ‘curing the world’ as he
put it.
And he started with some of his fellow anomalies.
The Plague Doctor started experimenting with
his new tools, concocting cures and serums
aplenty by pulling whatever he needed from
an endless supply of equipment and ingredients
at his fingertips.
He developed a cure for the condition that
had caused Daniel MacIntyre to become SCP-2800,
Cactusman.
His skin reverted back to normal, no longer
sporting spines, while the plant-like parts
of his DNA once again became human.
SCP-049 even offered a sympathetic ear to
a lot of Daniel’s troubles, helping therapize
him through a lot of his mental health difficulties.
SCP-2102 was also one of SCP-049’s successful
patients.
His condition of rapidly over-producing new
skin tissue when injured quickly became a
thing of the past.
Then, the Plague Doctor turned his sights
to the wider world, working tirelessly to
create new vaccinations and treatments for
diseases that were once thought to be incurable.
Everything he made and had the Foundation
distribute to those that needed it, was all
one hundred percent effective.
People were healthier and happier than ever,
all thanks to the Plague Doctor.
Until they weren’t…
In attempting to eradicate disease the world
over, a new strain of illness emerged.
SCP-049 took to calling it a ‘New Pestilence’,
and it was nothing short of horrific.
It would have been considered anomalous at
one time, but it quickly became so widespread
that it couldn’t be contained.
All the Plague Doctor’s advanced medical
treatments had encouraged this disease to
mutate, to adapt against everything he could
throw at it.
It could infect any person, at any time, and
present itself with virtually any symptoms.
It resisted drugs, any form of treatment,
and spread rapidly.
Eventually, while trying to come up with a
way to protect people from this strain of
super bacteria, this ‘New Pestilence’,
SCP-049 started to fall ill.
He had caught it, and even with his refinement,
he was beginning to weaken.
The Plague Doctor was dying, and once he was
gone, the whole world would soon follow as
more and more people caught the sickness.
There was only one thing he could do, a way
to leave someone behind to carry on his work.
When the Foundation – those that weren’t
yet ill – found SCP-049, he had already
passed.
But alongside his body was something smooth
and pearlescent: an egg.
And inside?
Maybe a chance for the world to be cured.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “WHAT IF THE FLESH THAT
HATES WAS PUT INSIDE SCP-914?”
and “SCP-049 - BOILED, SCRAMBLED AND FRIED
- PLAGUE DOCTOR TALE” for more pestilent
entertainment!